- I'm kinda finding it hard
to gather thoughts right now
because if you haven't noticed
there's a (bleep) snake on my face.
(energetic rock music)
- What are we doing today?
- We're getting snakes on us.
- I don't know why you're
so excited about it.
- We are going to try
massage therapy with snakes.
- I read on the internet about
this thing called snake massages.
- This man looks so happy!
- I can't imagine that's
what I'm going to be like.
- Why am I doing this again?
- [Ned] Esquire Network's
Team Ninja Warrior
challenged the Test Friends
to do something extreme,
so I'm bringing in a 12 foot python.
- Are you sweating?
- Yeah, I'm sweaty! My palms are sweating.
This is a normal human reaction.
- Why do you think people
are afraid of snakes?
- They bite,
but snakes are actually really docile
if you take care of them properly.
- Ugh!
- All right, so this is Casper,
and he's a ghost corn snake.
- Oh, he's adorable!
- This is Stanley the ball python,
and this is Swazi the ball python.
Any you wanna hold first?
- Uhh, I'll wait.
- What's a good way to hold him-- Okay!
Okay!
- Wow, look at his eyes!
- Hello, you're so scaley!
- I've like, never felt an animal
that feels like this before.
- He's a constrictor
so he likes to squeeze.
- Squeeze out the pain, Casper!
- It's Desha, bitch! (laughs)
- [Maycie] I'm gonna throw
up, or cry, or something,
I don't even know.
- I'm okay with the
snakes being on my back;
I would prefer not to
have snakes on my boobs.
- I'm gonna get the snakes on my chest.
I think it'll be like getting a hug.
- Let's (bleep) do this!
It's gonna be dope!
Probably, hopefully.
Okay, okay!
- [Maycie] Oh my god.
- [Jen] Okay!
- Mmkay.
- [Jen] This is not a sensation that I
have experienced before today.
- [Maycie] Oh my god, it's
going right by her face.
- [Jen] Doesn't smell bad.
I'll say that.
Feels kinda good, Maycie.
- I'm just chillin'.
I could actually, like, fall
asleep with these on me.
- [Jen] You know what?
They kinda feel like thin, long ice packs
just moving across my body.
- Buenos dias.
- If I shut my eyes,
I do sort of doze off.
It is very relaxing.
- There's just something
about watching a snake move
that kinda makes me nauseous.
- They're just like, kneading dough.
They were kneading the
muscles on my chest.
Ready?
- Yeah.
I guess I won't half-ass it.
I'll put the snakes on my face.
So (bleep) weird.
- I want a snake scalp massage.
And I want it now.
- Please take off your shirt. And--
- Wait, what? Are you serious?
- I'm just goin' off the brochure, here.
- [Desha] Don't act
like you don't like it!
- You ever seen a head more
ready to get a snake put on it?
- Alright, let's do this!
Here comes Casper.
- Okie dokie...
- My old pal.
- Yup, there's one!
- I'm getting goosebumps!
- Let's just, let's just
put the snake, okay.
Yep, yep.
Okay, he's on my face.
- I can hear him breathing!
Awww!
This is the best.
- Forgive me if I'm not the
most articulate, right now.
Holy (bleep), he's going
across my eyeballs.
- You know, sometimes you hear people
breathing in your ear,
but very rarely a snake.
- What is the point of this, again?
What are the benefits?
- I'm proud of you, Bergara!
- It's working, so far.
- It genuinely feels like
this amazing massage.
- [Ryan] He is just going to
town, right on the old package!
(laughs)
- Ohhh, I can feel his tongue
on the back of my neck.
- I could've done that for
like, four or five more hours.
- So I was already really
really nervous and freaking out.
Oh my god, I'm freaking out!
And then I'm laying there
on the table, head-down,
Ned tells me to turn around and
see the snake coming for me.
And it is enormous.
Uhh, wait, is it a big one?
Oh my god, Oh my god!
No, no, no! (laughs)
Like, the biggest snake
I've ever even dreamed up.
- So this is Big Worm,
probably about 12ish feet long?
And he's 50 pounds.
- And I did not sign up for that, at all.
I thought they were little snakes.
It was not going to be a big deal.
Ugh, even thinking about it
now just really freaks me out.
Ohh! I'm sorry, okay.
Oh god, oh god oh god oh god.
(screams)
Sorry, I'm so scared.
Ahh! Oh my god.
I'm sorry, you guys!
Oh, where's its head?
- Okay, okay... I don't know,
I was freaking out the entire
time, I never got used to it.
But I'm proud of myself
that I accomplished it,
and I did it, and I have it on video proof
for the rest of my life.
- I was really scared at first, but--
- It was really relaxing!
- I mean, as you can see,
I don't want to let him go.
- Can I take this guy home, or...?
- No.
- I'm very proud of myself that I did it.
- It did get more
relaxing towards the end.
- It felt like a real massage.
- You're not scared of snakes
then totally go for it.
- I dig them, I would
totally do this again.
- I'll stick with humans.
- [Ned] I'm gonna get a
taste of my own medicine.
See what it's like.
(screams)
Ahhhh.
Thanks for watching the Test Friends.